il ya trice du patrimoine archéologique
dans les yvelines va me rejoindre dans
un instant pour évoquer le travail mené
à elancourt autour du moyen-âge une
exposition à la ferme du mousseau que
vous allez être découvrir dès à présent
quelle taille avait hommes et femmes au
moyen-âge l'école existe et elle
comment se repérer dont les réponses se
trouvent dans l'exposition
un petit tour au moyen-âge à l on court
les enfants peuvent découvrir mille ans
d'archéologie et d'histoire
le but c'est pas un exercice est pas un
devoir c'est vraiment d'y prendre du
plaisir et de de sentir ce qu'était la
vie des habitants d'el en cours et des
yvelines au moyen-âge ou au moyen âge
puisque on divise le ménage en deux en
deux époques
mais pour cela on a voulu vraiment qu'il
ya une interaction entre l'exposition
est celui qui la visitent entre les et
les enfants ils encourent toi et ce
monde du moyen âge l'exposition et
ludique
un petit tour au moyen âge permet aux
visiteurs de toucher sentir et entendre
tout ce qui se passait à cette époque
voit les armes voir les pièces vers les
maquettes stade éboué de la guerre elle
a appris qu'on vieillit pas et guerre
tous les jours et que et qu'il avait des
vivants dans les cimetières
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
effectivement que les gens me l'ait pas
si mal que ça finalement à certaines
périodes du moyen-âge voilà et puis bon
qu'ils n'étaient pas tout à fait comme
nous effectivement plus petits
en taillant pointure que il mangeait pas
comme nous non plus qu'il y avait des bd
des légumes qui n'existaient pas et
qu'on en a aujourd'hui comme la pomme de
terre le poivron des choses comme ça
quoi comment se laver ton que cuisinier
tous les enfants lisent les réponses et
apprennent en soulevant les panneaux de
cette exposition proposée jusqu'au 27
février par le conseil général également
mise en place
des maquettes qui évoque des scènes de
batailles et de la vie quotidienne
l'exposition est seulement ouverte le
samedi après-midi et bonsoir à sandrine
lefebvre
bienvenue sur ce plateau médiatrice du
patrimoine archéologique pour les
archives départementales petit tour au
moyen âge c'est l'exposition qu'on vient
de découvrir à l'instant comment est née
cette exposition qui met tous les sens à
contribution pour les enfants ils
peuvent toucher sentir voir
alors donc je fais partie service
départemental d'archéologie et donc en
fait on a créé cette exposition en 2004
déjà elle a été l'idée c'était vraiment
de sortir un petit peu des clichés sur
le moyen-âge en proposant en plus des
clins d'oeil sur du patrimoine médiéval
des yvelines mais puisque donc on fait
des fouilles dans le département on a
des données sur le patrimoine ancien et
guy noah et donc on a créé cette
exposition en souhaitant qu'elle soit
vraiment tournés vers tous les publics
qu'elles soient ludiques et accessibles
à chacun
donc on l'a pensé itinérante pour que
chacun puisse l'empreinte est donc toute
structure yvelinoise même au dehors des
yvelines elle a déjà circulé en dehors
et donc depuis 2005 maintenant et
circulent un peu partout et là elle est
à découvrir donc
c'est des longs cours pour les scolaires
à peu près 600 enfants qui vont pouvoir
la découvrir du côté des longs cours et
puis pour les parents aussi puisque
c'est ouvert le samedi après midi à la
ferme du mousseau c'est une période qui
fascine toujours
on a entendu dans le sujet les adultes
comme les enfants il ya beaucoup d'idées
reçues autour du moyen-âge
oui bah c'est normal comme toute période
où le cinéma s'en saisit assez souvent
et dans des clichés parfois assez
poussées donc s'agace justement non pas
d'avoir fait ses salariés comme savoir
cinéma le cinéma sert à ça à sortir un
peu de voix lasse de la routine donc
c'est pas chez nous après c'est vrai que
si on veut vraiment des connaissances
faut se tourner plus sur des sujets
comme ça des expositions des documents
un peu plus fouillé et là on a justement
voulu le faire le contre-pied c'est à
dire qu on est à la fois des clichés et
on essaie de montrer que la réalité d'un
petit peu différente et la recherche qui
continue on n'a pas tous découvert sur
moulinage l avance et on fait évoluer
les connaissances aujourd'hui on ne sait
pas tout sur cette période dans le
département des yvelines puisque nous
sommes dans les yvelines on ne sait pas
tout sur ce qui s'est passé entre le 5e
et 15e c'est qu'on ne sait rien sur rien
et que quels que soient les périodes et
pour le moyen âge c'est pareil on a des
textes sûres qu'ils traitent surtout des
seigneurs des gens voilà qui sont
l'élite est décrit dans les textes
l'archéologie permettent de découvrir
des choses qui laissent des traces
matérielles mais tout ce qui ne laisse
pas de traces matérielles ben comment
l'approprier comme s'approprier les
découvrir les jeux c'est pas les
sentiments par exemple sont des choses
qu'on peut difficilement découvrir donc
à deschamps énorme de la vie de ces
sociétés pendant mille ans qu'on ne
connaît pas et qu'on ne connaîtra jamais
certes on essaye de trouver des indices
après justement la recherche avance pour
trouver de nouveaux indices se poser des
question différemment de prendre les
vestiges matériels ou fouilles sous un
angle différent c'est ça aussi notre
travail
les toutes premières fouilles justement
concernant cette période je voudrais
juste m'assurer de cette information
1713 les toutes premières vers poissy
c'est là que ça a débuté il ya eu dans
le département d'aidé des fouilles
effectivement assez ancienne au xviiie
siècle
bon avec les méthodes de l'époque on va
dire avec les approches à l'époque
changer ça a beaucoup jouent c'est
encore qui ont lieu actuellement dans le
département de oui oui bien sûr voilà on
est une partie de notre équipe donc du
service départemental d'archéologie est
sur une opération aux mureaux voilà on a
terminé il n'y a pas très longtemps une
opération dans une église à verneuil sur
seine justement il y avait des vestiges
du moyen-âge le cimetière médiéval qui
étaient dans l'église comme très c'est
très souvent le cas
donc on a pu un peu mieux comprendre
l'évolution architecturale du bâtiment
et l'évolution du cimetière aussi quelle
information surprenante vous avez
découvert sur cette période s'il ya une
information aux deux vous auriez coup
qu'ils vous ont particulièrement marqué
sur ses millions du cinquième au
quinzième jeu là une pharmacie parce que
justement des idées reçues peut-être
vous avez réussi ses différentes
fouilles à trouver
vous à dire voilà ça je ne savais pas
c'est une vraie surprise personnellement
en matière mais mes études j'ai un peu
du mal à vous répondre c'est que
justement j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
avec les études récemment qu'est ce que
je peux vous dire donc sur
verneuil-sur-seine par exemple la sq
était intéressant c'est que l'église est
un lieu d'inhumation au moyen âge il ya
une interruption et ça reprend un peu au
xviiie siècle
et en ce moment pourquoi y ait cette
interruption fait
voilà pourquoi quels sont les sites
peut-être à découvrir encore maintenant
parce que vous nous avez parlé des fois
qu'ils sont en cours mais ce qu'il ya
d'autres projets qui vont venir
cette année on a des diagnostics
archéologiques donc des opérations
préalables d'un aménagement qui vont
avoir lieu à cher par exemple dans la
commune d'achères et là on peut tout
espérer pour déclencher des fois il faut
déjà qu'ils aient des travaux qui sont
engagés en fait sur chaque chantier
d'envergure comme le vélodrome à saint
quentin en yvelines par exemple c'était
fait vous travaillez vous fait des
fouilles en fait l'archéologie
aujourd'hui elle est à 90% j'irai même
voir un peu plus de l'archéologie
préventive c'est à dire qu'elle se fait
en amont d'un aménagement été déclenchée
parce qu'il va y avoir un aménagement et
donc c'est pas pour tous les
aménagements bien sûr il ya des limites
et dans ce cas là le l'état prescrit un
diagnostic dont d'abord un diagnostic
c'est à dire on fait des tranchées
uniquement pour tester le sous-sol et si
les résultats sont positifs si vos
moyens intérêt scientifique
l'état va prescrire une fouille c'est à
dire on ouvre la totalité du terrain et
ont fouillé les l'ensemble des vestiges
en 7 environ vélodrome vous aviez trouvé
quelque chose est sûre si ça a été un
autre service à l'institut national de
recherches archéologiques préventives
qui avait fait les opérations et donc
cette exposition pour tout savoir du
moyen âge on trouve tout ce qui est
possible de savoir en l'état des
connaissances du cinquième au xvème
siècle c'est du côté des longs cours en
ce moment et puis et particulièrement
pour les scolaires il ya des cahiers
aussi qui accompagnait fait des clients
quelque chose tout à fait pour les
élèves adapté aux maternelles primaires
et collégiens
l'exposition est ouverte dès la
maternelle et oui ils partent pour tous
et vous saurez tout sur ces différentes
questions et y avait-il des souterrains
et les oubliettes dans les châteaux
forts qu est ce qu une croisade plein de
questions de ce type là impayés ton des
impôts également remercier d'être venu
nous parler de votre travail
et puis également de cette exposition à
découvrir et long cours
petit tour au moyen âge jusqu'au 27
février nous parleront encore culture
tout à l'heure et plus particulièrement
du mécénat autour de l'opéra royal de
versailles pour l'instant la page
environnement avec valérie auribeau qui
va me rejoindre